let's talk about this video with none
other than mr. Adam Kerr than yours
truly that would be me
so this thing's gone viral like it's
being shared thousands of times well so
this I'm shocked this is a video of you
during our rant from the last week so it
was last Monday yeah last Monday last
last Monday you started talking about
how you have decided you're gonna vote
for Trump yeah and you got some flack
for it I guess oh I'm still getting
flack for it people down today people
were like I don't know you anymore and I
was like whoa you know you want to talk
about it and they're like block I'm like
oh so you don't want to even discuss it
sure were you ever really friends yes
actually that's the sad part
like or rather I thought you know so
it's like whatever I don't think you are
I don't think you ever really were it
seems like it seems so you know it's
like if you don't I appreciate
everyone's opinion I wanted to hear this
person's opinion not gonna like say who
they were but regardless I was just
speaking my mind on when we were both
ranting we both kind of went on a rant
that day and my rant was basically
saying I'm sick of it I'm I've been
immersed in in the news and the counter
news and what's really going on hearing
the actual speeches by our current
President and how the mainstream media
actually portrays what the what he's
saying and I'm like okay that's not true
and I'm doing all my own research I
spoke about China a little bit about how
they're trying to take over and
corporations are losing a lot of money
by him trying to bring manufacturing
back we talked about how a lot of people
who said they flipped to join the Trump
train as soon as they actually saw him
give a speech and realized the media
been lying to them about everything you
know and so that was their like their
moment and then you mentioned that
similarly yeah you started actually
listening what he was saying and you're
like that's not what the media said
exactly that's great nearly every speech
of his is the city the same and I'm like
how you know how can that be like how
are they skewing it so far from what
he's saying that it's just them making
up their own narrative that they want to
push onto people and it's like I don't
like anyone pushing anything on me I
like thinking for myself and that's
literally what I said so and now it was
blasted liberal you know thinks for
himself thinks logically they
misgendered you the best part
libero says they're voting for Trump and
I was like he's clearly a man maybe
maybe it was the long hair that was
throwing him off and the beard hey no no
because there was that lingerie ad was
it for lingerie I don't remember what it
was for but like it was just like what
looked like a beardyman with lingerie on
it was something about women being women
I was like there there are there are so
I think that's that's fair point I think
I think they're being polite and not
trying to misgender you because they
didn't know well I'm a man and then it
can call me as such I'm offended that
you misgendered me so it goes two ways
people they did they they said they're
because they're trying to be polite and
it said liberal so they didn't know I
don't even know if I was considered a
liberal I just didn't pay attention or
because I was in my own little bubble of
world that I was lived in who was last
president voted for in 28 2008 I voted
for Obama yes bingo
yeah it's the first time I was able so
you weren't like a hardcore far leftist
or you know Democrat waving the party
flag or whatever you know but I think I
don't know who coined to this I think it
may have been Breitbart default liberal
okay like a regular person who just
lives in a city doesn't know doesn't
follow too much right and then goes and
votes for Democrat and so you were the
typical you know it's called passive
liberal I think according to the the
hidden tribes thing it's like people who
just live in cities and are just like
yep and they press the D button and if
they saw if those people that are were
like me that we're living in their own
little bubble saw that video of me being
a liberal like it said liberals using
logic thinking for himself and you know
doing his own research that's basically
what it said and that's what we were
talking about
they belated the video they deleted the
video it's been deleted all over the
place you know check it out
so I shared this two plus million views
Wow and I thought my rant would go viral
I told you I'm slowly taking over the
show so I did so I I had a rant where I
was like you got to stand up for
yourself and stop you know and blah blah
yeah and then afterwards allah grant i
actually got hit up by a ton of
high-profile people being like yo yo yo
we're sharing this can we can we talk
and people wanting to come on their
shows and stuff like that and i was like
i was like you know you know after the
show
kind of feeling people cuz people are
saying things like yo put that clip I
put that clip up yeah then all of a
sudden it was your clip yeah it's 2.4
million views on Facebook I was
surprised me though that the segment we
did with with both of the rants end up
being like half a mil on YouTube they
snip this one you know bit where you're
like here's why I'm doing it here's what
I think yeah it started to go crazy
viral so I I shared it and this morning
I got a notification on it and I looked
I looked the comments and people were
like that's really cool that you know
your buddy's thinking for himself there
are people saying things like you know
Adams kind of like a good everyman
representation and they're like it's
interesting to see his perspective and
then asked at this afternoon at some
point I went and it's gone
I don't know it's just gone and so
actually I went to the hodgetwins his
page gun you know so actually I sent a
message and I was like did you guys
delete this it's gone and I haven't
heard back or anything no and there were
other pages that posted to also gone you
know and then I look at what Project
Veritas said exist so if you guys aren't
familiar James O'Keefe Project Veritas
did this expose where an actual content
moderator I believe he was for Facebook
on the record with hidden camera footage
showing all these people saying things
like if it's a video of a trump
supporter I'll delete it for terrorism
yep so I wonder what happened you post
the hodgetwins you post diamond and so
if you post Candace Owens and their pop
the matter is our pie light we know who
they are yeah like there's nothing we
can do but also nicey a video of this
regular role you know vegan urban
beginning to do vegan hippie dippie
looking dude being like oh we gotta do
and they're like oh oh no we can't have
we can't have people like that thinking
for themselves we got to maintain
control uh-huh not if I can help it well
that's why we want that's one of the one
of the reasons why I wanted to lead with
this actual segment again yeah cuz I
will post it yeah we'll post exactly
about how they deleted it you should
keep doing it and we'll keep talking
about it yeah so this this this all ties
into this this bigger idea that because
we were talking about this and I'm like
man 2.4 million people and sharing this
video Trump supporters conservatives
right now are like they're at war I mean
figuratively you know they're like
active there they are paying attention
and then this story breaks from Adweek
check this out well I guess we can't
pull it up because let me see if I can
try and refresh it
give us yeah anyway you know what don't
worry about it the headlines right there
Fox News q2 2020 ratings tucker carlson
averaged four point three three million
viewers at eight pm the largest audience
in cable news history
wait when it say it says averaged so
that's over the course of the show
averaged so I don't know like he's the
entirety of his show it could've been a
little bit higher a little bit lower but
every episode he's averaging this is
this is Cable News history that's huge
Tucker Carlson is I've said it before
he's one of the best if not the best in
cable TV news you know if you agree with
all of his opinions no certainly has
conservative opinions but he gets he
gets very often his facts straight he
counted he's talented he gets that he
gets things wrong but the bigger issue
is that he's he you know he's very much
Pro Trump he's very critical of
Republicans he's been going after these
do-nothing Republicans quite a bit you
know by house the people who are
listening to him are not people who are
going to support Biden so who's coming
to Tucker Carlson to watch in historic
numbers people who are sick of what's
going on in our country right now which
brings me to two more points this one
first this is this is Candace Owens
right here we can see here where she
said she didn't support George Floyd has
ninety two point eight million ninety
two point eight mil and this is a big
news story that's a lot so for all we
know that a lot of use that's like most
voters so it's a lot of Democrats a lot
of Republicans but the point is no the
message is out there it's prominent and
you know this this George Floyd thing
I'm not saying that that has anything to
do with Trump it's just showing that
there's there's a substantial influence
from conservative personalities from the
right but this Politico article and then
we got this thread it's really
interesting look I've been saying a lot
that I think Trump's actually on it I'm
not saying he's going to lose I'm saying
he's on track right now with no changes
you will lose the way things are going I
it's I don't know I'm shaking my head
right now you can't see well I I don't
agree look at this right here what does
that say sharp decline in GOP
satisfaction with the way things are
going in the country yeah the Democrats
and independents so Democrats have been
going slightly down for a while but they
barely ever cared they've always hated
it since 2017 Republicans have been
kind of happy with even more than half
saying they're satisfied but what does
that statement even mean not happy with
the thing or sorry satisfaction with the
way things are going in the countries
like who's happy with what's going on in
the country or even the planet right now
of course nobody I'm not this is part of
why I'm saying if Trump does nothing
Rocky is on right now is is loss I'm not
saying he will lose I'm saying he needs
to change things okay which brings me to
the point actually being brought up by
this article and by another thread one
of the big arguments being that Trump is
waiting till after the DNC to pull the
trigger on all their big campaign moves
it makes sense he's already got
enthusiasm there's a major enthusiasm
gap people are going out and voting and
before he comes out and tries to do all
the the major campaign you know
advertisements wait for the wait for the
Democrats to announce their VP to
announce their their policy positions
and adopt their policy positions then
Trump can come out and start you know
dropping the hammer on a bunch of
different issues yeah but as of right
now things look bad you got bad polls
you got all this negative press you've
got secret insider saying Trump is
talking about quitting not that I don't
believe but this is really interesting
right here Politico said just a couple
of weeks ago that they have not fixed
the polls from 2016 boom the polls were
wrong in a lot of ways the National
votes were on point but the national
vote isn't that isn't relevant what
Trump is going for is the electoral
college you know anyone the electoral
college by a huge 25% yeah by it's a
huge margin yeah so how is it that he
lost the popular vote but he won such
huge numbers and they make a really good
point in this article but this is all
visit as another thread right here from
Carlos Oz wait up
that kind of breaks it down and and and
the point is these polls state polls
mm-hmm
we're not getting white non-college
educated voters yep they're like holing
the wrong people
well they kind of but is that they can't
get those people right the New York
Times talked about how they're trying
and they can't so they're trying to
adjust their margin of error and make
some estimations but they can't do it no
but if they can't get in touch of these
people's actually if they're biased
listen man when I during during Trump's
campaign in 20 20 15 and 16
I went to like 30-plus rallies mm-hmm
and I was I remember the one of the most
prom
one's like in terms of my conversations
and understanding I was in Florida I
think it was Fort Lauderdale I would say
9 out of 10 people I talked to said
they've they don't vote and I was like
you got are you Republican no Democrat
and I don't know and I tell you I tell
you this man I got a bunch of people and
they would say like I'd be like so you
know have you always wanted a Republican
but I'd actually don't vote yeah I'm
black but here you are at a Trump round
like oh yeah Trump's great and so you
had people who didn't even know what
they were politically you know these are
people probably never voted and one of
the things that happened in 2016 is
areas that didn't vote before that were
considered like gray because they didn't
vote all of a sudden turned red and so
we have this thread here calls us wait
up basically talks about a lot of these
really interesting things pointing out
that Trump is going for the electoral
college and he's turning states that
aren't battleground states into
battleground states yep by targeting
large groups of people who are
disenfranchised well you know who I
voted in 2016 2016 you vote in 2016
I didn't oh yeah that's my point oh
right yeah right so and now I'm I know
who I'm voting for you know and it's
like exactly yeah you know it's I have
become activated and more just active
like I just had paying attention now and
I'm like okay now I understand the
political realm to an extent I feel like
I I still don't know enough you know I
don't think I ever will know enough
because there's just so much to know you
know Democrats want Trump to win a joke
earlier but I kinda was serious though a
little bit so so make it easy for the
next 2024 let me tell you guys a story
oh my goodness this once in here in my
apartment right my house and I'm like
you know we got to do a new show so
that's why it's so I call up my boy and
I say to my boy I'm like hey Adam hey
come out here do the show with Mia and
I'm so I'm like yeah I didn't know who
it was at first I was like I'm like
who's this I look at that I'm like it
says Tim here but who is this why do you
have a really awful fake New Jersey sign
do you live in Jersey now no no no I'm
good
haven't you haven't you seen the South
Park episode where Jersey takes over the
whole country no no no South Carolina
Kota is now South Jersey anyway so I
call up Adam and I'm like hey do you
want to do a podcast with me because you
know I do this I do my show every
morning it's like and I already have for
whatever I want to do a nightly to our
podcast meet somebody who's like but no
politics no politics Adam I don't want
to do any politics we're the only rule
no Democrat no Republican conversation
not allowed to say those words right and
I was like yes cuz I don't know anything
about politics well so here now here I
am I'm like be I'm being like shared
around as like the new you know slogan
for ant you know bringing liberals to
the right to the Trump training so the
general idea was like so I do politics
all day and I was like there's so much
more that we could talk about in
cultural issues and stuff in movies
mm-hm if and we can do a two hour long
podcast we can talk about the universe
and aliens and just like fun important
stuff so we did movie reviews a couple
the apocalypse happened right no no it's
not the apocalypse come on I'm just
being I'm just Djokovic this is
important because we were talking a
couple days ago when they came for
dungeon & dragon Dungeons & Dragons and
imagine the gathering art got banned and
cards got banned then they started
saying certain like fantasy races were
racist or whatever stupidest thing and
and you were talking about how like you
normally didn't know a whole lot about
what's going on right and I was like it
wouldn't have mattered if I asked you to
come out or not because you'd be sitting
at your house with your friends playing
magic looking at your phones confused
why they banned a bunch of cards for
being racist probably not even that
probably probably not even that because
I didn't I didn't go out and look I
wasn't paying attention I did what's
there to even find out but somebody
would been like yo D & D is like the
rules are changing and never my play
group wouldn't have cared if they just
you don't think they would have noticed
on any of the any of the changes or the
share maybe maybe you wouldn't have seen
you wouldn't have seen the band lists
for cards like what is this and like the
statements issued in the car
being removed well I'd you know I didn't
I don't use any of those cards anyway
sure I checked the banlist sometimes
when I when I used to play but I don't I
I'm sure there was a gonna come a point
where I was like I'm gonna be forced
into this
I haven't yet was saying yeah everyone's
being forced into it and it wasn't this
it would've been the riots that's the
point I'm making right right well covet
everyone's home no one has jobs you know
now now people are even scared to go out
because of the riots like people are
like oh how dare these people pull guns
on them it's like yeah but they're
they're beating it they're killing
people they're killing each other like
how would you not be afraid of these
people surrounding your car beating on
your car shooting into a shooting shoot
at me oh yes shooting into the car and
you you think they're not gonna slam on
the gas now there's what check us out
ridiculous
there's murmurs people are getting
worried because apparently Provo was
like very heavy Mormon okay and in Provo
a it was a it was a SUV was driving on
the road these protests rioters
extremists we want to call them were
randomly running about so this vehicle
doesn't know there's a protest or
whatever you want to call it a riot and
it tries turning away when some dude
runs up with the gun and fires literally
shot the driver Wow police confirm the
driver got shot and then hit the gas
even even he's slowed down try not to
run people over and rush to the hospital
so the concern is like the Mormon
community is a community you know and
you just shot somebody and if that
turned out to be you know there's gonna
be a bunch of people who are gonna like
mm-hm they're gonna they're gonna start
gearing up and locking down and like
those people are ready whatever I've
been saying for over a month now when
you yeah when they've been they started
I was like man they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna hit somebody that
it's gonna be the final straw and and
the militias are gonna rise up so and
like what you just said exactly I bring
this up because in your in your case
where you're like the liberal who's like
you know start using logic or whatever
they want to say about you right it's
that when you didn't come to the fight
the fight came to you feels like like
whether or not you were gonna be reading
the news on Magic the Gathering it was
creeping towards you like that like an
evil is reaching out trying to grab you
yeah and then all of a sudden regular
people are finding themselves confused
what is this riot
why was I shot my dad got rushed to the
hospital with a bullet wound because
these lunatics are out there you know I
a lot of these people are not political
and if you want to talk about people who
don't vote all of a sudden voting in the
polls being wrong and this is how it
happens is exactly I'll tell you what I
look these people in South Philly or yen
South Philly where they can't they came
to tear down this the Christopher
Columbus statue mm-hmm first thing that
happens a bunch of a bunch of dudes come
out they got baseball bats they got guns
and they're pushing these far left you
guys around
I'm not happy about that by the way like
I've expressed this like they attacked a
leftist journalist guy let him film let
them do their thing but they roughed
them up because they don't care they're
here in my neighborhood and you don't
care these guys are in all likelihood
Polly voting Democrat because
Philadelphia is 82% Democrat so eight
out of ten of them may be voting
Democrat maybe not these guys now are
probably in my in my opinion not
political
there are just dudes who go to work
don't pay attention to the stuff they
want to go home they want to watch a
game with their buddies have a beer at
the local pub and now they hear a bunch
of crazy extremists are acting a fool
want to tear down their statue and
they're like what nah guess what the
city is gonna remove the statue anyway
really yep
they said the outbreaks of violence are
too much we're taking the statue down
Wow
now I can imagine these guys are like
what are you kidding mm-hmm and I
looking at the news the game's not on
there they're getting angry they're
getting agitated
the fight came to them well they realize
like the Democrats that are gonna that
are taking down the statues yeah I'm
speaking to them right now I'm talking
to you though people who vote Democrat
that are allowing these stitch statues
to be pulled down legally through their
means to take them all down it's like
that's destroying history when you know
you know a lot of Jewish people ah Sh
wits is still it's still standing you
know that yep you know why it's still
standing because the Jews don't want it
to be forgotten we don't want to forget
but that is what happened and there's a
big difference Oh is there there is
absolutely you know what you're right
you're right but it's the beginning but
it's still destroying the history of how
we got to where we are that's the point
I'm making the problem with the
Confederate statues is that they were
put up in
like to praise these individuals okay
aash wits is a symbol of the hora for
'[ __ ] you know acts and yeah cities
that's true that's true so that's why
I'm in favor of having a vote if the
vote passes we take the statues down we
put them in a museum we put up a plaque
instead but it's got to be done through
the democratic process because no one
has the right to come into someone
else's neighborhood destroy everything
agreed so I can I can respect their
position I can agree with their position
and I can completely disagree with their
use of violence and authoritarianism to
get what they want that's the problem
now come on taking down Christopher
Columbus is a step too far
taking down abolitionists and that's a
crazy George Washington is insane agreed
now they're going after the fourth of
July and they don't even know what their
what they're fighting for anymore so
I'll write all seriously what are you
fighting for they just want to burn it
all down that's they want to destroy
this want to burn it all down to that
and I think it's funny to bring this up
because it's supposed to be a trope of
the conservative commentators saying
liberals hate America right yeah but
these people literally do they just
desecrated George Washington and like I
mentioned they're coming for the 4th of
July so let me let me wrap this up and I
really want to talk about the 4th of
July
yeah me too because this is skits this
this this is what's gonna scare me I
agree with you so the general idea is I
think that you know when you look at
these polls they're not fixed they're
not tracking new voters they're talking
with likely voters you know and they're
talking with people who aren't read so
they're trying to figure it out but
they're not seeing though the everyman
or as they say the silent majority
you know so perhaps all of this is
shocking people to their core and
they're gonna go very very angrily to
that voting booth and just BAM right
there Donald Trump but the reason why I
can't tell you definitively is because
right here on the table right now you
can't see it is an official mail-in
ballot for someone that does not live in
this house no and we didn't request it
you know I don't know I'm pretty sure
nobody did the person hasn't lived here
in a very long time I know who it is and
none of us got these ballots so I don't
I think the system is completely
insecure if they do it this way I agree
yeah that's not confidence-building
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will sue
have this podcast up for free on all
podcast platforms thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you